you ever notice how it seems like every
popular franchise has a character who
doesn't talk
or barely talks and how they are always
so beloved snoopy check kenny from south
park
check chewbacca and r2d2 double check
pikachu groot hodor for crying out loud
check
check and screw you bran so you know
what guys i'm just gonna do a bit of a
rebrand from now on i'm gonna limit
myself to saying
five things matpat theory youtube
diet coke and subscribe youtube youtube
matpat
subscribe theory diet coke
aren't i adorable now
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that speaks the true universal
language complaining about movies on the
internet
today though i'm not complaining about
some cinematic stinker or even ruining a
childhood classic
no today i'm talking guardians of the
galaxy which is one of my
if not my all-time favorite slice of the
mcu pie
wait you didn't know that i love these
movies did you see the last guardians of
the galaxy
i haven't done a guardians of the galaxy
episode maybe it means that even for my
cold little dead theorist heart there
are some corners of movie dumb that
remain sacred well at least until today
and hey better late than never right
chris pratt
i never forgot about you and you know a
movie's good when you have a pratastic
lead a deadpan berserker who takes
everything literally and a smack talking
trash panda
and none of them come out as the fan
favorite of the movie because as we all
know
the fan favorite of guardians is clearly
groot
he's the guardian that we all aspire to
be eco-friendly
laid back tree person a few words and
it's that
last part that i want to figure out
today groot famously
says only three words
except when he doesn't at the end of the
first movie spoilers from five years ago
[Music]
and yet we're supposed to believe that
this is a language all its own
rocket raccoon doesn't have any trouble
understanding root's meaning i am
good uh-huh i'm good that's right and
he's not just humoring the old sap
but thor says in infinity war that he
took a class
on groot in asgard you speak groot yes
the total on asgard
so we know that this language is not
just specific to this one group nor is
it only understandable to someone who
has been around groot for a very long
time which is how i first assumed it
worked when i saw the first guardians
movie so anyway our
question today hinges on the reality of
a language
built around three words i am
groot would it be possible to have a
workable language where you could
actually communicate meaningfully with
those three words would it be possible
for a human to understand it and could
we
in the real world learn groot we're
going well beyond rosetta stone duolingo
and babble today kids we're talking
about
talking to trees and not the kind
that'll carry you to eisenguard we can
determine how feasible groot's language
is in real life from a few different
angles but they all require
just a little bit of knowledge of how
languages work and actually give meaning
to everything around us
so obviously vocabulary is one big way
that we get meaning we assign
different sounds to be associated with
different objects or ideas
keeps everything pretty straightforward
but it's hardly the only way to tell one
object from another
all the ways that we can assign meaning
to things around us in language is
called linguistic porosity
prosity refers to the properties of
syllables words and sentences that can
change the meaning of the overall
message sure we can change the words we
use
and that changes the message we're
delivering but there are lots of other
ways to change the message that most of
us never even think about
while there is no one standardized list
of every category and prosody
the four major elements are pitch length
prominence
and timber pitch just like in singing
has to do with the tone
or note of how you say a word or phrase
in english it isn't so much the specific
note with which the word is said that
changes like different keys on a piano
produce different notes but more about
how the movement of pitch creates
different meanings
if i say the phrase you don't like
cheetos with that kind of flat even tone
you know
i'm just saying that you're not into the
delicious puffs of processed
cheesy deliciousness but then without
changing any words i can say the exact
same sentence and move the pitch upward
at the end to make it a question
you don't like cheetos asking whether
you like them and clearly implying that
you have no
taste in snack food in other languages
pitch can change the meanings of the
same word entirely
the best known example is probably
mandarin chinese which is a tonal
language and has five distinct tones it
has a reputation as one of the hardest
languages to learn particularly for
americans in mandarin the word ma
can mean mother scold horse or hem and
figuring out which one is which depends
on identifying exactly which tone is
being used since
i'd probably butcher the pronunciation
and get dragged all over the internet
for messing it up i'm going to let this
lady demonstrate
[Music]
lots of languages allow for tonal
variation usually just with a high
medium or low tone but there are some
exceptions wobe
a language spoken in cote d'ivoire has
as many as 14
different tones now how does all this
relate back to groot well despite the
fact that groot is only using three
words
tonal variations on those words could
very easily give us anywhere from three
to fourteen separate meanings and then
combining those tones together could
generate a huge variety of meanings from
their combinations and that's just the
beginning
length is the next type of porosity and
it's pretty self-explanatory how long a
sound is can affect how it's interpreted
for example you're more likely to take
me seriously if i say hey then if i say
hey the elongation of the second one in
english tends to imply that i'm either
a little drunk or i'm coming on to you
but any elongation or abbreviation of
the way that we say a word in english
isn't going to change what the word
fundamentally means
just how we interpret it but in other
languages the length can
absolutely change the literal
interpretation of the words as well
with one of the best examples being
morse code in morse code sequences of
short and long beats known as dots and
dashes are combined to form letters that
will eventually spell out a message now
you're not gonna get a lot out of the
phrase i am groot if you're thinking in
morse code terms that's only three beats
and it takes a full 18 beats and morse
code just to say diet coke without even
adding hashtag not sponsored
on the other hand it would be perfectly
feasible that there's a difference in
meeting between
[Music]
and it's hard to measure the lengths of
words exactly you can use
music as a proxy and at least say that
you can compare the length of words to a
whole note
half note quarter eighth or 16th and
that gives you a lot more room to work
with so as long as groot can keep time
by tapping his
i don't know he doesn't have toes his
roots i guess he can get a lot of
different rhythmic variations out of
that single catchphrase
we'll add how many different variations
to the calculation in just a minute
the next bit of prosity for us to
consider is the one that i experience
every time i get a phone call from a
number that isn't
saved into my phone dress or even when
the number is saved into my phone it's a
phone i don't want to talk to you also
known as accent
or emphasis or prominence ironically
linguistics can make up its mind about
what it wants to call its own terms
anyway the meanings of phrases and
sentences
can change dramatically when we either
stress or don't stress a certain part
my favorite example of this is actually
a meme that's melted the brains of
redditors for years
the sentence i never said she stole my
money has
vastly different connotations when you
stress each different word i never said
she stole my money indicates that
somebody else accused her of being a
thief i never
said she stole my money implies that you
think she probably jacked your wallet
but you weren't going public with that
i never said she stole my money means
that she stole your bike or your heart
or your netflix password
and so on and so on and so on this one
is pretty binary in that you can stress
a word or you can leave it unstressed
but that still multiplies the number of
ways group can say
i am groot by a factor of eight i am
groot i
am groot i am groot i am groot i
am groot i am groot i am groot i am
groot
eight eight different varieties thank
you ladies and gentlemen vin diesel eat
your heart out and the last bit of
prostity we're discussing
is timbre talking timbre of a talking
timber am i right
oh the dead jokes are just coursing
through my veins today timbre is the
hardest of the prosodic elements to
define because it's pretty subjective
but in layman's terms it's the sound
quality that's being produced this can
get super technical if you start using
terms like micro intonation
prefix and spectral envelope but we all
experience timbre in ways that are
easier to describe like vibrato
there's certainly a difference between
saying groot in a normal voice and
modulating it to groot
and then you've got things that are hard
to quantify but easy to differentiate
like sound quality like in dumb and
dumber jim carrey's most annoying sound
in the world
okay okay cut it that's enough the most
annoying sound in the world is just a
note that is obviously going to sound a
lot different from the same note played
for the same length at the same volume
from say
an oboe one sounds like music and the
other one sounds like a goose being
shoved through a paper shredder fun fact
in college i took a voice class that
focused heavily on timbre our professor
made us develop a voice called the
hollow wood voice i literally spent a
semester trying to talk
like hollow wood also metal voice metal
voice there it is that's what i did for
an entire semester
ladies and gentlemen the life of a
theater major ironically enough even
with a name like hollywood i am still no
better at translating groot
what a waste that was hollywood this is
actually part hollywood part broken
earth putting that college education to
use
now from here we keep going down the old
timbre road if we were to include things
like coloration
and sound quality and vibrato at which
point the permutations of
i am groot would be infinite but timbre
rarely affects the meaning of language
it more affects the experience of it
morgan freeman's voice
doesn't fundamentally change what's
being said it just makes it more
soothing
and buttery what does the fox say a
ring-a-ding-ding i don't know what it is
with morgan freeman in my episodes
lately but
like butter therefore i'm gonna leave
tambour out of the calculations though
groot's timbre would definitely
fluctuate based on his mood
i'm rude i'm grouper i
am grouped so is there enough variation
in the way that groot can say
those three magic words to make it an
official language well let's imagine a
best-case scenario
if we say that groot's language has as
many notes as wobey's 14 that length can
be distinguished into whole
half quarter eighth and 16th notes to
create different meanings and that the
meaning changes when a word is stressed
or
unstressed well we get a lot of
different ways of saying that phrase
two million seven hundred and forty four
thousand ways to be exact
maybe that's being a bit too optimistic
though so if we keep the tones but
instead of using all those
differentiations in length and instead
focus on whether the word is short or
long like in morse code we still
end up with 175 616 different variations
of i
am groot for comparison the second
edition of the oxford
english dictionary gives the english
language a strangely similar number of
words at 171
476 so the number of ways that we can
say
i am groot are at the level of the
english
language not too shabby i for one am
pretty darn happy with those findings we
have made a solid case for groot's
language here but
i can see you arguing that this can't
actually work because there's no
real world language that works this way
no language just works with three words
and just modifications and tone and
rhythm and stuff there's no
proof and you know that's a reasonable
complaint or
at least it would be if it were true the
fact is plenty of languages exist with
limited vocabularies the created
language tokipona only has 123 different
words and while it relies on creating
compounds to create more complicated
ideas much like
german does it's able to express a lot
of complex thoughts but that's a
manufactured language not a language
with any native speakers
says you the stickler who should really
stop watching my videos and just start
cashing in on your vast trivia expertise
jeopardy is calling to you friend
alright so if you only want to count
languages that are native to a specific
real world culture
somewhere on planet earth at this moment
there is a real world language that
gives us a new minimum of words in a
vocabulary
and that number is zero on the canary
islands the native silbo gumero language
is composed entirely of
whistles no spoken words
whatsoever that sounds like you probably
can't say much with it but you would be
incorrect
[Music]
so there you go groot's three word
vocabulary is three more words than a
language
actually needs which then by proxy means
that we could learn to speak groot
right fans could gather at comic con
like trekkies do at conventions except
instead of speaking klingon they'd be
speaking groot
no you can't as much as i would love to
see it according to maximus the mad
in the war of kings series it's likely
impossible
groot only sounds like he's repeating
his name over and over because of his
hardened larynx
and the key to understanding him is to
listen to the sigh of breeze beneath it
the nuance of meaning for one listening
for some kind of magical breeze is not
really an area of porosity but more
relevant is the hardened larynx bit
humans do not have a hardened larynx and
it's not worth trying to figure out a
way to get one because in people a
hardened larynx is actually a serious
medical condition
in this condition called presby larynx
people have incredible difficulty
speaking loud enough to be heard easily
and usually have to find other
non-verbal forms of communication like
sign language
to help so at the end of the day the
condition that would allow us to speak
groot would actually prevent
us as humans from speaking any words
loud enough to be heard at all
guess we'll just have to stay rooted
come to terms with the fact that when it
comes to speaking root we won't be able
to branch out
but hey i am groot i
am groot i am
holiday theory where is still available
so if you like
soft cozy oversized things with hoods
and in the color black
well boy howdy did we create something
for you
we're calling it holidays in the hood
because
well it's cold outside so we wanted to
keep everyone cozy warm with a hood
hats coats sweater dresses pj pants even
this film theory hoodie has a hood
ladies and gentlemen unbuckle your
safety belts because we have reached the
altitude of
peak comfort links are where they always
are down in the description below
and if you order in the next few weeks
it's all guaranteed to arrive before
christmas
but don't wait too long because a lot of
the items are selling out fast